[موسيقى]
في ذلك اليوم كنت أنظر إلى الأسفل
وجاء مغامر وشوهد المسار
سقط العميل الطائر على وجهه نعم
لأنه لم يكن لدي وقت للصراخ عليه
زبون
أبيض
[موسيقى]
أنا مارتا 1 أكثر من يوم وقد تأطرت
الأصغر
[موسيقى]
اثنين من المياه
في البداية أنزلناها مع السلم
نحن مثل هذا مع البيتزا التي تسير معنا
كنا متعبين للغاية ولم يكن الناس يعطون
أفكار و فكرة ذات سدس
انزل المسار عبر الشرفة
[موسيقى]
طريق
في بعض الأحيان يطلق عليه طريقي لأن
أنت والمسار طريقك و
منا أكثر مما أشعر به
الكثير من الضغط الذي تحبه مجموعة الكشافة
انفجرت الدورة الأساسية في الدرجة الأولى
زيارة في العجين وفي الصلصة وفي كل
الكلمة لها الوصفة الخاصة بك كل الرؤى الخاصة بك
صلصة بطريقتهم لا يقولون
سر
نعم ، لقد حاولنا الاحتفاظ بملحق
نفس نوع العجين
هنا العجين يدوي
[موسيقى]
جودة الأجزاء
جيد بلا شك هنا يأتون
يذهب الناس الشاطئ من شاطئ البلدية
لا أحد في 4x البيتزا يساعد الكوبي
لأنها تساعد الناس على البقاء على قيد الحياة الآن
التسريبات
هذا يجري الثلاثاء بدلا من أ
الخلفية الخضراء هي أكثر من جانب جيد من
أي قنصلية مالطية يمكن أن تتخذ
أي قرار نتخذه لدينا
القوة لتقرر ماذا
يفعلون أكثر مما هو أفضل بالنسبة لهم
عمل أحاول دائمًا إنجاز الأمور
نحن نبحث عن الضحك والضحك
في الضحك يجعل يومك و
الابتسامة لها قيمة هائلة
[موسيقى]